I think the biggest misconception
about people that are tattooed
or about getting tattooed is that,
it has this stigma
and people, think that people
just want to look bad ass.
Laura Schaack,
thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Good morning to you.
Good noon.
Yeah. Good afternoon over here.
Good afternoon to you.
Good night to me.
That's what I love about,
corona times have been
very timing for a lot.
But this getting to adapt
to all these different times,
it's been pretty, pretty fun,
especially in a show like this.
Thank you for joining me.
I'm incredibly excited
to talk about tattoos,
of anything tattoos.
Laura, are you a tattoo artist
besides being a tattoo entrepreneur?
So, I'm actually not a tattoo artist.
And I think that's what has been
the detriment of a lot of people
that have attempted something
in the tattoo and tech space.
The majority of founders have
been tattoo artists who decide
maybe I want to build an app.
I'm coming from a different angle, right?
I've been working in tech
for the last 10 years.
So, like tech is my trade,
tech is what I know,
building apps is what I know.
And I love tattooing.
And I'm super heavily tattooed.
And I've got a lot of tattoo artist friends
here in New York.
So, I'm definitely coming at it
with a tech lens.
And the learning curve
is really the artistry side.
But it's a really interesting topic
to have as a learning curve.
So, what does that mean
when you say heavily tattooed?
Give me the details of it.
I'm heavily tattooed.
I've got a full sleeve on my arm.
I have, a couple,
sort of random ones here and there,
about half my left leg done.
I love that.
So, before we get into the tattoo space,
who are you Laura?
Give me the rundown of how you got
to be a tattoo entrepreneur in tech
and we'll dive into that intersection
a little bit later.
But I want to learn
a little bit more about you right now.
Yes. So, I kind of hop on
upon the tech scene, right?
And it happened, I think before
it got really, really popular.
And then Silicon Valley came out.
And now every gen Z
or just wants to be a founder
and be their own boss.
And that's really cool.
But there's a lot more to it
than that, right?
Those are really hard.
But there's a lot of pressure
a lot of stress,
a lot of constant work.
So, it really wasn't romanticized for me,
honestly.
I was working in a
international nonprofit space, actually.
And I needed something more fast paced.
I came here to New York when I was 17,
went to NYU, got out,
started working in the nonprofit space
and was like, this is great
and I love that I'm making an impact,
but it's not enough of an impact for me.
So, I need a type of industry
that is super fast paced,
that is going a mile a minute,
that is ready to try really innovative,
really risky things to see if that's
the optimal way of doing things
that probably only describes
the startup industry,
to be honest to you.
So, I sort of accidentally
moved into the startup space.
I was one of the first employees
at an incubator
that moved European SaaS companies
and integrated them into the US market.
I lived abroad.
I worked in Madrid, Spain, for a while.
So, I think these European entrepreneurs
were sort of like,
great, she has European experience.
And also, she's the only
American on the team.
We need a little both on the team.
So, this really took a chance.
I sat there and I took this job
at 23 or 4.
But I thought I just gonna travel Europe.
That was what I thought I was doing.
I didn't know at the time
that I was kind of entering
the early stage tech startup space.
Little did I know,
fast forward not even six months,
and I'm going to pitch competitions
and I'm talking about
go-to-market strategy,
and I'm talking about product market fit,
liaisoning with CEOs and CTOs from Europe
way earlier than I probably should have
in my professional career.
And sort of went on to really be
really well integrated
into the startup scene here in New York.
Right?
So, I also joined some startups
to build them from the very ground up.
I went through a number
of accelerator programs here in New York.
I'm in here for one now, actually.
And I think in a little bit after that,
I also worked at
some app development firms
It's little different
but they're understanding
of the tech side of things.
So, the idea for Tattd came about
much further along than
than whenever I started it, right?
I've had this idea for almost five years.
I only started it about
a year ago because
I came to the point where I was like,
first of all, it took me a long time
to become brave enough to do it, right?
Like, I had seen founders.
I'd seen the really ugly side,
like the really scary side,
the really tense side.
I work for the startups that aren't like,
the Twitters of the world
where you just get free snacks all the time.
But, you know, there's some people
I'll meet on every the events,
some people are like, "Oh, yeah,
I work in the startup industry, too."
And I'm like, "But which type?"
I work to the type where you're unpaid,
working on the founder's apartment building.
Like we've had different experiences.
Do you know what I mean?
But I finally came
to a point in my career, I was like,
okay, I've had sort of this
trifecta of experience, right?
I have worked in incubators
where I'm seeing companies at scale.
So, the SaaS companies were moving over
are like series A, Series B level,
7, 8 years old, really ready to scale,
they have a lot of capital behind them.
I've seen things launch with very little
to no money from the very ground up,
and I finally have, after working
on some app development firms,
a thorough understanding
of the technology side of things.
So, I feel like I had sort of this
trifecta of experience
that would allow me to start Tattd
and make it really, really successful.
Even though I had this idea
for a long time.
So, hopefully, that's what I'm doing.
That's amazing.
So, let's go back just a little bit
the intersection of you.
You have this idea for Tattd
for about five years.
And we're talking about the tattoo market
and we're talking about a marketplace
that matches tattoo artists
with people that are looking
for their artists.
And so, talk to me a little bit
about the market,
because I really know nothing
about the tattoo industry.
I've been thinking,
and if my mom and my dad
and my girlfriend listen to this,
then I'm in trouble,
but I've been interested to understand
what is the tattoo market?
Why are people getting tattoos?
What is the benefit
or what does it do to them
emotionally or psychologically?
So, please teach me a little bit
about what's happening there.
Absolutely.
So, I think the biggest misconception
about people that are tattooed
or about getting tattooed
is that, it has this stigma.
And people think that people
just want to look badass.
And everyone has that story
of like their drunk sorority sister
that got some horrible tattoo
or whatever the case may be.
And we all smoke on the cigarettes
and maybe ride motorcycles
and like probably will curse at you
in a coffee shop line,
you know what I mean?
Like, this is the idea
of people that are tattooed.
And it is so inaccurate.
And I need like mainstream media
to stop making that portrayal.
I think people need to open their eyes
to the actual community of people
that are tattooed.
Tattooing is an art.
So funnily enough,
half my coursework
at NYU was art history.
Whenever I was like, a child,
I volunteered very young
as early as I could get a job
at the art museum.
I grew up in Austin, Texas, in Austin.
Like I thoroughly have
an understanding of fine art.
And tattooing is an art, right?
These people are usually
like illustrators or painters
and sort of come and start tattooing.
So, tattooing is really significant
to the tattoo artists,
but also a lot of the times
to the person getting a tattoo. Right?
People get a tattoo of sort of like
in memoriam of people that have passed.
People get tattooing because
it makes them feel empowered
about their body.
You know what I mean?
it's really closely aligned
with their identity and it's something
that is really special to people and
is a way to express themselves. Right?
It's not something that people go and say,
"Now, I feel really cool
and people can't talk to me anymore."
That's not it at all.
It's actually extremely special.
And I think millennials are really
kind of getting a hold of that.
Millennials and Gen Z,
people can say a lot about them,
but they really do push boundaries
and they really do
sort of defy the status quo.
And I think that's really benefited
the tattooing industry. Right?
They're no longer
pulling away from that stigma,
and people are getting into it.
There's also a trend within
that sort of mentality
that is sort of like
a personal brand customization.
You know what I mean?
And it's a question of
who am I and how do I differentiate.
What I remember growing up,
it was all about fitting in.
I think I was just sort of
on the cusp of that change.
So, it's really interesting
for someone my age,
I'm 29, if anyone wonder.
But I think it's interesting
for someone of my age that saw
what it was like that
the mental was to fit in
and become homogenous.
And now I have seen a huge shift,
and the mental is absolutely not that
if anything, it's the antithesis of that.
It's more like, who am I,
do I fit in with this people
or do I not.
And what is my individuality mean,
and how do I express
or define that individuality.
And so, I think that also sort of
spurring more and more.
I mean, the number of that show
the industry is increasing,
but I think, that's why.
So, give me a little bit about
the numbers of the industry.
Do we know how many
of the tattoo artists are out there?
What is the demand for it?
How many tattoos are being administered
on an annual basis, stuff like that?
Yeah.
We know that there's
145 million Americans
that are tattooed,
which is just about half.
Wait. Half of Americans are tattooed?
That's right.
What?
That sounds crazy.
A crazy number.
That's in 2019 data.
145 million.
Half of the US is tattooed.
And half of them
have more than one tattoo.
It's not just like one little one off.
You know what I mean?
A quarter of Americans
have more than one tattoo?
Yeah.
That's like the best engagement
of any product I've ever heard.
I mean, it's amazing.
And it's like, it's incredible to me that
not a lot of people
have really tried to harness the space.
This is a huge market,
It's a huge market and it's only growing.
it's gigantic.
Americans are spending
1.7 billion dollars a year on tattoos.
Billion with a B.
It's crazy.
And I think there's
a lot to say for the fact that
it's sort of this distraught industry.
There's not a center fine force to it.
There's not really leaders in the market
because all of these
are sort of individuals.
They're all individual freelancers.
They are small businesses,
the small shop in the corner
of that neighborhood that you go to
because you befriended.
That's so interesting.
Yeah.
How do you explain then
that there is such a big stigma
around tattoos,
yet, half of Americans have tattoos?
Yeah. It's interesting.
I think people maybe get tattoos
and then maybe distance themselves
from the tattoo community.
So, there's a difference between
some that had a tattoo
and someone that is
part of this cult, if you will,
for lack of a better word.
And you know, people are very insular
about allowing other people
into that sort of cult mentality. Right?
And I think that has a lot to do
with the fact that they
have been stigmatized
and have been semi,
not discriminated against in a way
that many other groups are
for many other reasons.
But the stigma has sort of allowed
heavily tattooed people,
people that are a lot more heavily
in the industry than you know,
just having a one of tattoo.
Unless you really sort of band together
and nearly reject other people entering
the tattoo industry.
Which is also something
that Tattd is fighting, right?
So, I remember the first time
I went to go get a big piece.
I walk into the studio and I was like,
"Okay, I have a tattoo idea.
This is what I want.
Can someone talk to me?"
And I got the stink eye of a lifetime
from this woman.
And she was just like,
"Can you just look up our artist
and contact the artist directly?"
You don't do that.
Like as if she's like, "Get out."
Wow.
I didn't know it operated like that.
You can't just go to a shop
because the shops are literally just
shares essentially
that they rent out to people.
Like you contract with the tattoo artist.
Yes.
I had no idea.
I thought you walk in and you say,
"You look like a great artist.
Come here and I want you
to draw something on me."
No, not personally custom.
So, I mean, they have like again,
like pushing towards to stigma,
but on the street with all the bars
on any given city,
there's probably tattoo shop
that you can probably walk in
and choose something off
of a laminated page in a binder
and get that tattoo.
That is not at all how the majority.
I thought it was more like a haircut,
that you have a big bunch
of different styles
and you can come in and say,
"I want this style now."
I had no idea.
A haircut you would have forever.
Right.
So, now it makes so much more sense to me
why there needs to be
a dedicated marketplace.
Because if you're contracting the artist,
first of all,
it doesn't make too much sense to me
that you only have access
to the local artists
that are you're seeing
in your a geographical area,
because if you're getting
a tattoo for life,
maybe you're willing to travel
a little bit farther
for that special artists,
five hour drive,
that can do something very, very special.
So, now it makes perfect sense.
Please keep going.
Absolutely.
And there's also an issue with sort of
the data being very distraught.
So, when you're choosing a tattoo artist,
having all of the different data points
available to you is actually essential.
You can't just have one.
So, when I say data points,
I mean the artist's location.
I would love to go
and get tattooed in Tel Aviv,
probably not today.
You know what I mean?
So, location of the artist is essential.
Price also is essential.
Because prices can range from,
they usually go in hourly rates.
They can range from like
a $100 an hour,
I've seen some four $800 an hour.
$800 an hour?
$800 an hour.
I have seen it.
These are like celebrity tattoo artist,
but still.
I think I'm switching profession.
You should.
I think my fallbacks
should totally be tattoo artistry,
you know what I mean if this isn't work out.
That's incredible.
How many hours does it usually take
to get a significant tattoo?
Yeah. It can be anywhere from,
three to twelve.
It really depends on the size
and the detail.
Really?
Oh yeah.
The average tattoo cost is about $2500.
The average tattoo cost is $2500?
Yes.
Or that's maybe the average amount
that a person has spent on their tattoos.
That is still incredible.
It's in the thousands.
Yeah.
My tattoo is worth thousands.
If I'm comparing it for a second
to the streaming industry,
that's probably pretty much
what a person would pay
for Spotify, Netflix, Hulu,
over their entire lifetime.
Right. Exactly.
So, we're pretty much on the same size.
Okay. So, that's fascinating.
Talk to me a little bit about Tattd.
And talk to me about the challenges,
about the traction,
what insights have you gained
as you've been building this marketplace?
Yeah. Absolutely.
So, what we built is essentially
an intelligent search where
we're combining the ability to search
by location, price range, specialization.
So, speaking about to sort
of my history with art,
a tattoo artist specializes in a way
that is very significant
whenever you're making that choice.
So, a tattoo artist
that does impressionist tattoos
like a [--] fine art
doesn't do like pop art,
Andy Warhol stuff.
That's not the same person.
In the same way,
if you want a tattoo artist
to do like script tattoo
or if you want a tattoo artist
to do Americana,
you're not going to go to someone
that does the opposite thing.
You know what I mean?
So, you need to know
their specialization actually.
So, a tattoo artist by specialization
and you can even search by keyword
if you want to see a certain image,
if you want to see a butterfly
in their portfolio, fine, you can search
by a certain image as well, right?
So, you have all of these options.
Typically, what the user would have to do
is go to Yelp if they want to know
the location of the studio.
They would have to go to Instagram
and go on a hash tag of specialization.
Find a great artist,
wait there in Berlin.
There's no cohesive data.
So, that's what Tattd
has brought together.
The app itself
has actually gone beautifully.
Which is probably
because I've made history
in actually building app.
So, it's like, that part has gone
really, really smoothly.
And we've got an amazing,
amazing responsiveness.
The number one thing
that I hear back is
how is this not been built before.
Right.
After this conversation,
I'm shocked myself.
I have been shocked this whole time
that I've been waiting
for someone else to do it.
I don't even know if I want to do this.
Because this is a little work
you guys someone else needs to do this.
And no one did.
And so, here we are.
But I love it.
It's like a labor of love.
And watching it
sort of gain traction and come about.
I mean, in the first month
we had 2,000 downloads.
We're only opening 12 launch cities,
the 12 most tattooed cities in the US.
What are some of them?
New York, LA, Austin, Miami, Denver,
Portland, Houston, San Diego,
San Francisco, Chicago.
All of the main ones
that you might imagine.
And I believe that these are also
the 12 main tech hubs of the US.
Yeah. Funnily enough,
the urban centers seem to follow
both of those trends for sure.
But what I want to do is make sure that
there is a strong database
in each of these cities. Right?
So, imagine I just like launch,
anywhere in the US.
What if you're in a Richmond
and like only two artists
have sign up there?
That's going to be a horrible experience.
And here I am looking at my app and say,
"There's no artist here actually."
Like, bye.
So, I was like,
all right, we need to concentrate
and limit a number of cities,
build a really strong database.
I want hundreds of artists, like if not,
like a thousand plus in each city,
and then I can launch
and get even more.
I want everyone on this app.
The kind of other thing to mention is
that it's free for both sides,
which no other platform
has been for artists.
Which is so horrible for them,
because these artists,
you know, they're trying to make
a living off of their art.
And it's not easy.
They have to pay
for their own health insurance.
Even if they're in a studio,
they pay for all their own materials.
All the ink you see,
which is very expensive,
all the machines, very expensive,
all insurances for their actual art.
It's literally everything they have
to actually pay for.
And then a studio
takes a cut on top of that.
So, making an artist pay for a platform
in order to promote themselves
can make any sense to me.
So, it is actually free for both sides.
And we still figure
out a way to monetize.
But that was really the important to me
just because it is a huge mission
to empower creative industries
through tech and allow these people
to not be paycheck to paycheck
for their whole lives.
So, that was really important.
The other thing that is of note is that
as I was becoming more acquainted
to the community and this was
very much a grassroots movement. Right?
So, instead of going
from the very ground up
and like, you know,
going to top tattoo artist in the US
and getting them to endorse us
or whatever it is,
I was like, all right,
they already have a following.
Like, they already have enough business.
I want this to be a grassroots movement.
I want it to be real.
I want to speak for the people.
And that means for us as users,
but also for the tattoo artist.
We did tons of,
sort of micro influencer outreach.
We did an ambassador program
where literally I would take
30 minute calls with every single artist
that partnered with us
that wanted to be on the platform
and told them about the mission
and heard about their pain points
and all that.
And we got all these people
sort of behind it.
Now, as I became more and more acquainted
with the community
and probably after, as we're building
our social media presence
and sort of defining our brand,
for me and my value is that
diversity and inclusion of all people,
of every gender, race
and shape and size
was always going to be a part of this.
I thought I was going to get
sort of a nod from the tattoo community.
Like, yes, that's what we believe to.
Thank you so much.
Moving on.
Because of the counterculture, right?
It's a counterculture.
In my head, that meant,
that it was not subject
to the white male paradigm, you know.
So, it was like, great, okay,
we probably don't have to worry about that.
Little did I know,
the more I connected with people,
they were merely informing me
of my own mission.
And I really connected with people,
they were saying,
"Thank you so much
for being such a strong voice
for the LGBTQ community and tattooing."
And I was like,
"Am I a strong voice you had?"
I thought we were just
being inclusive and being diverse.
And the more and more I realized
that it actually is a huge issue
in tattoo culture,
which is shocking to me personally.
But it is at the end of the day,
when you think about it,
there's no HR department
for tattoo artists.
You know what I mean?
There's tons of stories about women
being harassed by shop owners,
you know what I mean?
Or worse.
So, there's no one
that's able to police that,
or is able to set these standards.
So, Tattd became to be
a really proactive voice for that,
nearly accidentally,
to be really honest with you.
And the more and more I got the response
and I had people reach out to me saying,
"I will work for you for free."
I had creative directors,
I had interns.
I had developer reaching out to me
that is connected to the community
that says, I had literally,
some come to me and said,
"I am gay and I have
never been comfortable
walking into tattoo parlor.
Thank you so much.
I would love to get a tattoo,
but I just don't even feel comfortable.
I want to work for you."
That's just remarkable.
And it's incredible.
Laura, thank you.
Thank you for this inspiration.
Thank you for sharing these stories.
And it's amazing how that
the side effect consequences come about.
And I'm sure that that fulfillment
of hearing these remarks by people
that haven't felt comfortable
showing their passion
or exhibiting their excitement
over this industry,
it's just, it's really, really great.
So, it's a really fantastic job on that.
Thank you for doing good for the world.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you
for the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself
The hardest question.
I would say authentic.
You usually get sort of me
unfiltered at all times.
For better or worse, authentic.
Passionate, if you didn't already notice.
Very passionate at everything I do.
Yeah. Definitely. Definitely
An adventurous I would say.
I feel like I usually am really ready
to try something new
and go out on a limb and take a risk.
I love that.
Laura, thank you very, very much.
Best of luck with Tattd.
I know it's just the beginning
of a long journey,
but it sounds like it's off
to a great beginning.
So, best of luck and I look forward
to following the journey closely.
Take care.
Absolutely.
Thank you so much.